vous êtes chant et tirer les gens j'en
peux plus tu es fan de lever le pied
parce que j'en peux plus alors ces 13
j'arrête là mais non mais attends il
assied il à chaque fois ont ils fait
sortir ça changera rien moi j'veux pas
et dossier tu continue à faire des
vagues nu suis désolé moi je peux pas de
nom mais ce nom faut-il en hystérie
j'arrête j'arrête aussi dont il faut
quelqu'un mais est ce que quelqu'un peut
m'aider pour thierry moreau mais qui
vous voulez qu'ils faisaient mais j'en
sais rien moi mais on peut dire quoi
aider
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous
oh
alors voilà pascal je suis désolé de
vous je sais que c'est pas très
professionnel de ne plus présenter
l'émission mais là j'ai craqué je vois
voilà sa mère me l'a confié cyril
hanouna elle a essayé de les éduquer moi
j'ai chez les ducs à ma façon j'ai
essayé de faire mon rôle de père et il
est indécrottable fait toujours des
mauvaises vannes ne fut pas visiblement
maintenant ça suffit pas et ce que vous
pouvez faire quelque chose pour nous
voir jusqu'où je peux donc ouais donc
mis le sujet en masse tutoyer d'accord
pourquoi tout amusé à faire des vannes
pourries on a vu ça te fait rire en plus
ça fait rire j'ai le tome 2 de cloud ça
fait pas peur non juste rien fait encore
moins que il y un solent et les autres à
jour sa joie sa voix visiblement avec
vous aussi ça ça fonctionne je pouvais
faire ce que je veux avec toi oui c'est
si je passerai jamais douloureux au
départ une fois pascal pascal est ce que
tu te fasses que le moment est grave
est ce que tu peux arrêter la musique
est ce qu'on peut faire quelque chose
pour tout un change et de sueur qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour l'empêcher
faire des mauvais zone au moment où il a
envie alors moi j'ai une idée je pense
qu'il faut une fois du matériel déjà
donc il m'a sorti du matériel il faudra
la part fait beau car s'il est bien un
bien vous prêter au jeu
ça vous dérange pas parler fallait un
costaud parce que je sais pas quelle
force tu vas quelle puissance tu as tout
simplement tu m'as l'air bien costaud
très peu de puissance je vois ça je vois
ça mais bon si puissante et 20 de parts
contre nous oui c'est dur c'est dur
c'est dur alors qu'est-ce qu'il va donc
qu'est ce qui va se passer parce qu'elle
commet tous les enlever le but en fait
c'est patent temps calme toi l'équipe et
on tient pas mais moi je ne tiens pas à
se vendre
c'est par oak hills et d'artagnan c3po
si tu comptes faire mal à quelqu'un avec
ce type de coup de poing tattoo fois pas
contracter ban active un pardon je fais
mal mauvaise vanne d'accord tu fais mal
à tout le monde moi tu fais mal à me
fait mal c'est vrai je fais mal a toutes
les qualités
tu fais mal au public moi ça me fait mal
d'entendre tout ça j'en peux plus moi
j'en peux plus donc il faut que
t'arrêtes désormais à chaque mauvaise
vanne ce que tu vas faire soit
extérioriser de tout ce qui va pas ça
ce sac là on sera désormais ta façon de
parler tu as fait rebondir les choses
d'accord je veux parler tu mets un coup
est-ce que vous pouvez montrer comment
il faut tabler sur la clé pied
actuellement qu'est ce que tu veux les
pieds plutôt je suis pas très soupe à
tout faire les pieds n'ont pas aidé ma
pardon parce que j'ai pas fait ça c'est
compliqué parce que ses pieds sont les
mains c'est ça donc pour les mains je te
conseille de mettre des gants d'accord
invasif tous les bons si tu venais à
auch les goûts et saveurs comme ça
aurait été autre les gants et ses
affaires une vague de ma tête au niveau
c'est compliqué ce qu'on va faire on va
faire on va faire un quizz pour toi
thierry la cobas tu peux t'en sortir
voilà je te donne des phrases qui
concerne les clips et tu dois aller
compléter si et si tu réponds mal tu
tapes d'accord d'accord tu es prêt
thierry oui alors mes mails bien les
deux grands et encore parce qu'elle vous
pouvez donner juste un coin je vais
montrer ce qu'ils voient la fanfare donc
se mettre face ce serait vachement
bouclier attend attend la faute bien
l'écouter c'est important alors si un
jour tu un petit peu dissipée pas la
réponse est non tant cela je le paye
quoi on t'arrête tout ça va se passer
d'accord donc nous donc simplement un
coup de poing direct mais voilà ça
permet d'extérioriser tout ce que tu as
la caisse qui va pas ok là c'est autre
chose c'est ce que je vois
donc ça je peux t'aider aussi pour ça on
va faire un test
donc tu dois compléter la phrase ok ça
concerne gilles les propos de gilles ne
manque jamais de piquant c'est normal
car verdez ça rime avec avec piment à la
lépi si si ça c'est pas mal comme le
faire on essaie de choses ça concerne
isabelle c'est normal qu'ils connaissent
toujours bien ses dossiers car c'est
elle qui prépare le plus l'émission oui
on peut pas dire mais isabelle morini
bosc mauvaise vanne tu vas tomber trois
doubles et unique chose car tout point
ces murs dont je sais une dernière en
2014 avec les élections municipales il
va se régaler jean-michel la mer non
sans michel aphatie parce qu'il fait pas
la politique lui donc tu tapes trois
fois kanepi cas là tu as toi
[Applaudissements]
et si plutôt que écrin pour quitter une
mauvaise manip chez nous tu tapes ion se
serait c'est possible aussi
jeckyll paire de gants annonçons les
grands hommes et non pas ce qu'est ce
que vous pensez que c'est bon on peut
leur a envoyé à sa place pas moi je
pense que je pense que tu gardes les
gants sont orange a invité pourtant
c'est con way bassa les cons seul
compris elles sont pas prêts sur moi
mais j'espère j'ai confiance en toi
vous avez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]